Bueno antes que nada Muchas gracias por
la invitación podemos
reseñar una progresiva clausura de la
participación de las mujeres en la vida
cívica institucional
educativa política de Afganistán desde
el retorno de este actor al poder como
gobierno de facto hemos visto distintas
medidas Primero este año el hecho que se
limitara
la presencia femenina de estudiantes en
edad secundaria es decir niñas de 12
años para arriba para poder regresar a
las escuelas es una medida que fue
repudiada por distintos organismos
internacionales por movimientos derechos
humanos y por mujeres activistas afganas
dentro y fuera del país y ahora nos
encontramos con esta nueva
este nuevo anuncio que limita ya de
forma decisiva e indefinida el ingreso
de las mujeres en las universidades
hasta entonces desde el retorno de los
talibán en las universidades las mujeres
estaban estudiando de forma segregada y
solamente se les permitía
recibir lecciones de profesoras mujeres
se habían segregado los ingresos a los
edificios ahora directamente
este anuncio marcaría que ya no podrían
siquiera participar de del espacio
áulico y hemos visto que haya habido
condenas por parte de la comunidad
internacional estas condenas podrían
afectar al reconocimiento Internacional
del gobierno talibano finalmente se
podrá imprimar los intereses económicos
sin dudas que digamos el gobierno de los
talibanes las Afganistán está teniendo
serias dificultades en demostrar hace
como convincente respecto a las promesas
que había hecho en el momento del
retorno cuando se habían presentado con
una opción moderada respecto a la
experiencia de los años 90s nada de lo
que estamos atestiguando da indicio que
esa sea la dirección que tomen por lo
contrario las mujeres ya no forman parte
tampoco del funcionariado público es
decir del servicio Civil del Estado
afgano en este sentido
junto a otras medidas Como por ejemplo
las que comentábamos recién en términos
de educación Pero también otras
cuestiones que hacen a la al gobierno de
las vidas cotidianas de las mujeres
afganas cada vez más difíciles de
participar en espacios públicos en
plazas en calles sin la presencia de un
marido que las acompañe un Custodio
masculino que las acompañe está
provocando repudio como decías de
organismos internacionales Sí y por lo
pronto
el aislamiento para Afganistán ha
resultado en la merma de recursos y
sobre todo de fondos de los cuales
vivían muchísimas familias en el
interregno de dominio norteamericano de
tutelaje norteamericano en este sentido
recrudece la situación económica
Afganistán que ya se ve una especie de
callejón sin salida